[Music]
i am a child of the 80s born in 78. you
were born in 81.
so that's when we experienced our um
childhood so uh i loved 80s movies music
some of my favorite movies uh had an
actor named michael winslow michael
winslow did these incredible sounds with
his voice like um the sound of a dog
barking in the distance or a machine gun
that was so
accurate it sounded like the real thing
he was a virtuoso with his
he's famous for being in the police
academy movies that's what people and
spaceballs spaceballs are the big ones
right yeah what i love to me those were
like some of the best movies police
academy especially i loved all of them
you know i can name the titles the
subtitles of all seven you're so proud
of this very proud um and i got to one
day work with michael winslow i was
doing a show called ed and he was a
guest star on one of the episodes so i
met him in the makeup trailer and i said
i told him what a big fan i was and he
was very
nice very appreciative and uh
i said i asked him you know you can't
meet michael winslow then not ask him to
do one of the sounds one of the one of
his noises and um i asked him to and he
said uh sure and he started humoring me
so he started doing the machine
and like the distant dog
you know i can't do him obviously but um
that wasn't bad the dog one
the first one first attempt was better
oh [ __ ] quit while i was ahead
and uh i was like ah that's great for a
little while i was like you know five
maybe ten minutes and and then i had to
go i had to work and they were calling
me to set so i said oh michael thank you
i'm gonna head out and go well i'm
heading out too i'm leaving the trailer
i walked out first i opened the door
and um i heard this creek
like a creaky old door opening i looked
behind me and he was smiling he was
doing the sound of the door
and i smile and i started walking down
the steps of the trailer and i heard
oh no
i helped
and he was doing those sounds and and i
kept walking and we're walking together
now and i'm trying to like you know get
to know him he's like somebody i'm
working with he's
a person that i now like to know a
little bit better outside of what he
does and i said so you know where are
you from and he goes i am from the
planet of zebelbach
oh no no but seriously where are you
from
oh i don't know where i'm from you know
like
was just doing voices and i i couldn't
get through i couldn't and he's been
with you ever since
he never left your side
yeah so here he is michael you want to
say hi hello that was good
uh
anyway you are listening to life is
short
i'm your host no i can't do that it's
gonna be too annoying you are listening
to life is short don't do that
okay life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long who does some
noises life could be a dream sweetheart
is my my brother christian who also um
you do some what do you do what's your
voice what's your go-to sound effect
my go-to sound yeah if you have to do a
sound effect your best one go my best
one or my go-to one aren't those the
same thing no i might not be good at it
oh okay well what would you do if
somebody put you on the spot like
want one oh yeah that's a good one wow
it's pretty good
but michael winslow can you imagine how
good he is at that
he's amazing uh and there's another but
but that's pretty annoying uh yeah i
mean because he wouldn't do much of that
is annoying too much of that and then um
he was such a nice guy though i uh i i
should stress that because then then
when we started shooting there was a
really funny for another for another
time it's a long story but um why are we
talking about michael winslow well our
guest today
is
hmm how do i i don't want to sound he's
so many things but he is it's too uh
small to say that he's a modern day
version of michael no because he's not
one of the elements of him because
there's so many things that he does and
he's one of our he i think he's one of
the most unique and talented and
great odd performers um but one of those
elements is that he is michael winslow
adjacent he's he's he himself is a
virtuoso with sound effects and noises
and our guest today is um the totally
unique hilarious reggie watts
totally unique totally well 80s maybe
i'm just thinking of the huh totally
unique he is uh most people know him i
would say as
the um
like the inventor of the light bulb yeah
um is james corden's uh what is it
did you not know how to say like because
all those things i almost said sidekick
or right-hand man or like i don't know
definitely didn't say that almost to say
that uh but i almost said sidekick yeah
and that's and that's insulting because
he does sidekick especially for reggie
because he's like he is such um
he's so impressive on his own he's like
the ed mcmahon
or the andy richter that's that's more
insulting than sidekick because he's ed
have you seen ed mcmahon i mean like
andy richards
i i
i think ed mcmahon is a tough company
andy richter is great yeah but uh but
that's the role he felt he was thinking
of like an old rummy who likes
talk show right i know why
psychics shouldn't maybe shouldn't be
insulting
sidekick i'm thinking of like robin or
like i like robin yeah but you'd much
rather be batman
robin quivers oh yeah sidekick too yeah
but i always identify more with um robin
than batman because i i
duh uh yeah right you don't have to
explain it
the boy blunder um so reggie is well
whatever he is you know that he is the
guy on the show who uh
let's just just say for argument's sake
he's a he's a sidekick co-host okay okay
he's um that's people know him as that
yeah but he is a lot more well he also
um had an incredible still does stand-up
career but even to say he's a stand-up
that's the thing about reggie you can't
kind of just have to hear yeah okay and
so let's do it yeah just hear from you
you knew him a little bit right i did um
oh no how did i meet reggie years ago
uh who cares you know i know him yeah
how the [ __ ] did i meet reggie i don't
know i just feel like i've known him for
a while and uh always love being around
him we've had a lot of fun together
we've gone to concerts and we talked
about i tried to get him into the
bachelor one year he it was so funny as
a contestant no
no no as a um a fan
i tried to draw him into bachelor nation
oh i see and uh he we had so much fun
watching it um
you gave him a citizenship test
yeah it's any he passed the test but he
didn't want to uh take up residence
there
so um but oh my god that was had a fun
night watching that with him and uh this
was such a fun uh catch up with my my
old friend so here it is
uh my ketchup with reggie they're
totally totally unique
uh one of a kind truly one of a kind you
can't say that about many people
but i can about reggie here he is reggie
watts
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
that name i want to
know where that name came from how did
reginald is just so great it's erudite
sounding
you know it's my uh
birth certificate name it's um uh it's
also a very european thing to like name
multiple multiple names
um
but uh yeah it's uh uh
lucian was
lucian lucian yeah was a friend of the
well technically it's lucian but uh lucy
lucian was uh
mr lucian was a
friend of the family of my mom's family
when she was growing up he was a really
cool generous guy so so she named so
that that's from him and then frank is
her father's name and ho ji
is um her brother-in-law's name
she i didn't know she's she's french
she's fully yeah from france yeah she's
a she's a french head yeah she's from oh
well she's from uh she's from a little
village called tul
t-o-u-l-e
have you been there i haven't been to
tula i'm actually i might have been and
maybe i did when i was really really
young but when i used to go for summers
um growing up i never remember going to
we'd mainly stay in these little
villages outside of mets like
like little tiny like you're just down a
country road and it's like here's a
village and then like five minutes
here's a village
two minutes here's a village you know
um
so you grew up speaking french i mean
just your pronunciation of those words
wow yeah yeah i mean it's funny i i
learned it uh through just the sound you
know it's just oh no yeah it's just just
by sound because when i in high school i
thought i'll just breeze through french
class you know because i know how to
speak it
and at first i was totally
like rocking it and then once the
grammar started getting more complex and
all of that stuff i was like oh [ __ ]
do you remember any of those early years
i know you were born in germany but your
dad was in the air force so he must have
traveled around a lot do you remember
any of those
do you have any memories of those places
the only place i because we moved to the
united states when i was four um so the
only place i really remembered was
i think spain a little bit i think we
were still he stationed somewhere
i think we lived in madrid but it was
somewhere that was close to madrid so i
remember a scene like i remember being
on the the fire escape because it put me
on the fire escape sometimes to play
you know that's what you do when you're
four stories up um but i think we were
three stories up but i remember looking
i could see through you know you can see
through the fire escape the floor of the
fire
and so um i was looking down and i and i
remember seeing a yellow car parking
and uh and my mom was like oh that was
your babysitter she she
drove a yellow car
i was like oh that's crazy so that's
really the only memory i have oh my god
from back then yeah
so
you're at the fire i'm hung up on the
fire escape now we had such different
parents
so that they would just kind of leave
you to your own device they weren't like
uber protective i mean it was different
back then i mean i i think yeah i'm
older than you are but they they were
i don't know my mom was like
or
no she was no she was like 30 fussy 60s
70 80.
90. i guess that would make sense yeah
she was like probably like 35 or
something 36 my dad was
45 48 or something like that oh wow so
they were older already but also from
just older generations and uh
uh
i think i think like safety was just
like yeah that looks pretty safe you
know but you know
we're good
you know
what what and why um god that's nice to
hear reggie i always like hearing lately
i've found myself liking
hearing that there's
stories about older parents because i i
really want to have kids and um
you know getting up there oh yeah yeah
yeah i always forget because you're like
one of those eternals
you're like 35 now 36. i i as a matter
of fact just turned 24. oh [ __ ] okay i
believe that it's fine
yeah and it was eternal
that's funny
you want it yeah no good
do you want to have kids or is that
something you'd like
interview over um
i meant with me oh right right well then
yes um
no no
no yeah
in the early days of my life i was super
hardcore now
um oh now now
i'm now i'm like
i'm pretty sure i'm not very interested
in it i mean i am sure that i'm not
interested in it but uh
[Music]
you know i might maybe i might meet
somebody and maybe things i mean jeff
goldblum had his first kid in his 50s
that's right mmm yes can you do a
goldblum i see it he is he yes yes yes
yes
yes yes you know
yeah it because it comes up here it goes
down yes
yeah yeah it's the breathing what if
strange cadence i love hearing him talk
i got to send you these text messages
because i've
i keep asking him to do every like seven
or eight months i'll ask i'll like reach
out to him hey because he said
two years ago that he wanted to do the
podcast and i was like great and so um
he keeps uh he keeps saying he doesn't
want to do it but in very
sweet and funny and like quintessential
jeff goldblum ways you know sir i would
um well i would love to mix our
sounds together out in the ether
um yeah
yeah but i think yeah i i think nowadays
i'm just like more more leeway to like
what if i did run into somebody and
maybe i want to you know like foster
sounds interesting maybe adopted because
my whole thing is like i understand why
people want to have children of course
um you know it's it's if you're feeling
it like i get it you must be so good
with kids too yeah i love kids like i i
i really love kids but i'm kind of like
one of those
like when you're kid's six years old i'd
love to come visit him like
because it's like a baby it's like i
don't know it's like i'm just like i've
been on babies i've held them and i'm
just like
i know they don't really do much i mean
they don't do anything no no they're not
supposed to because they're on vacation
and and some people are like really good
at communicating at that level you know
yeah like they they see these like micro
adjustments and like these like things
where they're like oh they're looking at
their hands and they're doing that you
know and obviously parents i mean you
know you're there and you're like
fascinated with every stage of course
yeah not to discount that but like
generally for me i need some kind of
like what you were saying i need some
kind of interaction i need to i need to
be like oh yeah what do you see over
there well i see the todd thing dinosaur
over there like oh yeah that's right did
you know that dinosaur you know like i
need at least that
yeah to go into uncle mode you know
exactly but you but again like once you
are there once they can give you
something i you strike me as somebody
who is like oh i love it just great at
playing oh i love it i love like you
know imaginary games um you know just
coming up with stuff or tricking them
all the time in a really funny way yeah
like i i love that and probably my
favorite age range would be like 10 to
16. something like that oh really that's
that's a little bit more my zone just
because oh interesting just because you
know 10 you're pretty you've got a
pretty good strong sense of identity you
know and and but you're still like
you know obviously in adventure mode and
uh everything's new and you know um
whatever and yeah and there's a pure
they're they're not kind of like there's
like more this is gonna sound really
creepy out of context but there's all
the parents are just like you guys are
so terrible oh i'm sorry that's not what
i meant i love you my favorite age is
six to eight yeah
[ __ ] you man every age everybody
but you um but i i think i'm hung up on
like the idea of you i'm imagining you
interacting with them in um because
you're so good at sound of sounds and
yes right you must blow kids minds with
that kind of stuff oh yeah yeah yeah for
sure i mean it's fun yeah you can make
like weird like noises or sound like
noises coming from a different place or
you know whatever all that kind of stuff
100 yeah and i love it i love it it's
great because my thing is like i i like
it because it's fun but also i want to
be a good influence on kids you know i
mean you know not all the videos on
youtube would go in that direction but i
would say uh
there's a there's a general playful
nature that i think you know a parent
can like go
these are these words but he's actually
it's kind of a friendly
positive person um
but uh
but yeah i i definitely
i i just i i love inspiring and showing
different ways of being like different
there are different ways of thinking you
know like oh you can approach it like
this you can approach it like this and
it doesn't have to just be this it can
be this don't be so hard on yourself you
don't have to have these rules you know
yes that kind of stuff i think i'm
really good at that
is your mom still in montana yeah yeah
oh so you've been going up there i have
yeah i have been um oh good yeah i have
uh yeah i've been up a few times i try
to go once a month well why why montana
how did you how did she settle in
montana
well my dad was stationed uh after spain
to um great falls montana because
there's the air force base there
malmstrom air force base so
he was stationed there so we moved there
and uh and then he retired there so we
just kept living there
and what was that like growing up there
and
was it how rural was it i'm imagining
like very woodsy
beautiful yeah i mean well montana is
definitely that but great falls is a
it's pretty much
it's uh you know it's six about 65 000
people
uh um and uh so it's like a suburban
yeah it's kind of suburban-y feeling um
but a city that's all like that i mean
there's a cute downtown you know like a
old american style
downtown post-industrial and then um
or actually industrial i guess it would
have been around the industrial age but
uh yeah so there's like a cute downtown
there's a you know it's all the stuff
two high schools a river that goes to
you know that the missouri river a river
runs right now
i know
no it's true i mean in this case yeah
it's true i mean we're not even
no but but uh was there a lot of fishing
now i'm just picturing um you and
waiters and like oh yeah no no no no no
i wish i mean i did go fishing growing
up but i i wasn't ever really interested
in catching fish
and so and i remember that's so weird i
remember i would go with my neighbor
robbie from across the street they had
this little truck camper
and we like would drive to you know a
lake and and uh
we'd sleep in the camper
and
uh we'd go fishing in the morning in the
boats and i don't know what you do you
know how it is when you're camping you
can't remember what you're doing it's
just like you're doing stuff and then
the day goes goes by um but uh i just
remember him making his dad making
sandwiches and they were like
white bread
with butter
or margarine
and a slice and a slice of bologna
oh god that was the sandwich
that's great falls uh no i mean
but great falls is great falls is cool
monty i mean i grew up in the
late 70s 80s um there
and
it was awesome i mean you know was there
like a
culturally or music scene or or for
somebody reggie like to look like with
mixed-race parents was that
weird was that were you like
yeah i mean there's always like there's
always things with that you know my mom
was always uh very
um
thing little things can trigger she was
always on the lookout for anybody
treating my dad or me you know with
any kind of lesser lesserness yeah um
and uh
yeah she
yeah so so there were definitely
disagreements we had arguments with like
a neighbor across the street down the
street who
called me the n word
uh
told me to get off his property that
kind of thing like classic in a way i'm
kind of glad it happened because then i
have that classic story you know it's
just like
classic you get off my you know whatever
yeah classic racist story this sucks i
feel really terrible about myself maybe
i'm not good enough
you know um but yeah but um
but but which was so you were obviously
i mean like i was gonna ask you like
were you aware of that and like that but
obviously
in a moment like that it's like yeah i'm
pretty aware yeah yeah you get you get
aware pretty quickly i mean
i mean you know i always knew that i was
different for sure i mean i never really
fit in anywhere i actually thought this
um
i saw an article recently i think i sent
it to my ex and she uh because she's
half lebanese half polish
and and so i'm half white french and
half african american and uh
we kind of compare notes a lot about
that stuff and
and and for her she could pass as white
enough you know she definitely has some
kind of exotic features but she just
passed it passing enough and for me it's
like oh i was dark so that was that's
what i look like but um but i where'd
she grow up reggie she grew up in new
york upper west okay yeah so she was you
know in a pretty diverse area anyway
yeah but for me i was definitely i was
just always aware that i was a different
kid you know my mom was french and had
an accent and you know and i looked
different and i wore weird clothes and i
had nutella before anybody it did
was your dad because he was in the
military did that strip any of his like
cultural identity or his identifying as
a black man
i would say he probably acclimated i
think he he was in the service you know
he was in vietnam twice
oh wow and then and then he
that was in the army and then he got out
of the army and then
and then wasn't really in the civilian
life so he wanted to get back in the
military and then applied to the air
force and he had so a good such a good
record with the army that his commanding
officer gave him whatever just a letter
of recommendation or whatever and he got
into the air force
i think he was pretty comfortable in
caucasian culture you know like where is
he from originally cleveland ohio
oh oh yeah wow did he have like come
from a very working-class
family yeah i mean you know pretty
hard-working uh working-class family for
sure i mean my his his mother was
jehovah's witness
his father is an interesting story
um his father my grandfather who i never
met
uh
was
a a gangster and would run the numbers
um and he would transport uh cash and
like outcomes of bets and stuff like
that across town
and he got he got like busted once or
something but um nothing major
and uh and then when my dad
was 10
his dad was having affairs
on his mom my grandma and then
one time he
was in a he was in a i don't know some
room he was in bed with
a one one of the women that he was
cheating on my grandma with and then
another mistress
came over and caught them
together
and they were both so angry
they stabbed him to death
no
i'm
look on your face i just love how you're
like expecting something like oh that's
funny they got mad and
and
oh my god they stopped seeing those
people oh my oh my god
oh my god my grandmother never forgave
him no you never forgive him no you know
oh my god reggie that's crazy isn't that
crazy i mean it's so crazy my dad was 10
at the time so oh my god yeah so uh
yeah so that that was my oh that was
traumatic
i know for my dad i know it's like you
know and i wish i would have gotten to
know my dad a lot better because um he
was a quiet dude you know because he was
a vietnam vet he had that
did he not he probably didn't talk about
those experiences no not i mean soldiers
back then from like vietnam era unless
you know unless you're surrounded by
some pretty awesome awesome people that
are like fighters and like like you're
getting your therapy for this you know
because there was no such thing as ptsd
that that wasn't a thing right
and um
right i mean there was shell shock and
things like that but like uh
you know there wasn't a formal kind of
more empathic approach to
unwinding trauma
and then also just drinking a beer you
know and just sitting in the dark i
would like go up to use or go get up to
use the bathroom sometimes my dad would
just be sitting in a chair at 3am in the
dark
oh man you know so i know he had a lot
of i knew he had a lot of issues and i
wish i had the skills you know back then
to
ask him a lot more about that stuff but
it just
it just i for whatever reason i never we
never got to that that level in a
relationship
and you know any of his friends reggie i
mean like do you are you still in touch
with any of the people that he knew or
maybe served with
no no i wish i mean there was um
i guess i don't know if they served
together but uh my mom's best friend
janine who is also french who married a
uh american uh her husband willie was
was pretty good friends with my dad
because they were both in vietnam and so
they had a lot of
familiarity because of that and i'm not
sure if they actually knew each other
uh at that time but um
but yeah so there was that guy and and
then anybody else i didn't really know
you know because again he never really
talked about it
and did he save any of his like any any
trappings from back then like any photos
or his dog tags or anything like that i
think i think there are dog tags there's
dog tags there's an old army helmet
um there's uh
i think uh like a utility belt
um and a
some like
things that you whatever like little
pocket sachets that you put on the the
belt and
and definitely some photographs like
because i had all my pho all my uh
photographs digitized
uh put on a hard drive
yeah
wow isn't that crazy that you think
about like all how open
how like
how aware we are of our feelings and
talking and communicating and and we we
over share i mean like all the things
that we are like look at what we're
doing right now i know i know and like
well how do you feel about this and your
dad the things that he must have seen
and gone through and [ __ ] it's like
and that just
never came out it's crazy to think i
think about that with my own
not that they were in the army but
people my own parents people from that
generation how much they kept to
themselves yeah it was just a thing you
know it's just kind of what that's just
kind of what what you did you just dealt
with [ __ ] on your own like how are you
feeling oh i'm fine and it's like real
yeah you know meanwhile their back is
like in total pain but wait if your
dad's mom was jehovah's witness um did
she was she really against him fighting
in the war because aren't they pacifists
uh i think so i mean i don't know if his
dad went to was in the war or not um his
his his dad would have been
oh oh okay right you know i guess he
could have been in he could have been in
probably world war ii maybe or world war
one actually you probably would have
been in world war one but but she didn't
care about your dad fighting or um your
dad
yes right uh
[Music]
you know i don't know and i'm not sure
i'm not sure maybe she wasn't jealous
witness like
when maybe she converted after
her father died or something like that
i'm not totally sure i need to figure
that out you know her your grandma yeah
yeah grandma william
yeah she was great and then uh she
married this guy um i actually didn't
no i never knew his first name i just
called him grandpa roosevelt
because he was roosevelt something
roosevelt um
but he uh yeah you know and i used to go
there in the summer and
yeah some summers because i alternate
going to france some summers and then um
going to cleveland while i was growing
up
and uh and that was weird because like
i'd go there and
you know kids would make fun of me
because i have a big nose they'd be like
ah pinocchio
and uh
at night so i never quite fit in there
you know so i felt weird plus i was i
grew up mostly
you know around
whites so so um
there are a lot of whites where i grew
up mostly white and white in montana
whites and montana yeah but what about
so when you what about cleveland
cleveland was all black when i was there
so so that's why i felt out of place
because i was used to
that right oh yeah you know and so i
went to cleveland it was like all black
like you know deep in the black
neighborhood you know and uh and were
they like you talk white yeah you sound
like a white yeah they would say you
talk weird you know you talk funny um
wow and yeah you have such a unique
style what how did you cultivate that
like when did that start the improvising
and that the looping technique um
how did you start infusing that into and
into comedy i i think i was i was always
just a
a weirdo performer kid you know like
were you always were you whistling would
you walk around kind of
whistling and beatboxing oh yeah it'd be
i'd be mimicking singers from the radio
you know like i walk around and do like
let's get physical by living newton john
or i'd be
you know uh or you know imitating
[ __ ] michael jackson or you know ray
parker jr or something like that so i
was always singing pop songs and i would
sing them on the playground too and do
kind of this bit where i would have a
coat
that'd have like this like little belt
with dangly things and um and i would i
would just stand in the middle of the
playground motionless and then someone
would come up and they'd yank on the
string and every and be like
every woman it's solid
and then they would they would pull it
again
and then every time they'd pull
everything
some guys have all those
excuse physical you know so that's great
it was like a radio on the plane oh that
must have been a hit that was awesome
yeah it was great i loved doing it and
it was just a blast and that was like
probably third grade
were those so you must have been i mean
you said kids were making fun of you um
saying you had a big nose but did was
that in was that in one place versus the
other was that just in cleveland oh that
was just in cleveland yeah for sure
because you know everybody there pretty
much had flat noses flatter noses and so
for me to show up and there's like they
didn't get it you know they're like oh
what you know and um
but uh you know i mean it was it was
like
fat albert style you know it's just like
ah man he got a big nose ha ha ha fat
albert hey hey he doesn't have a big
nose but he's a good guy
right you know right there is affection
yeah there's still affection there yeah
i mean sometimes they were trying to
hear like you know jerks but it was like
jerks i mean that was like the highest
level of animosity right it wasn't like
dark [ __ ] it wasn't yeah yeah they
were like trying to inflict damage they
were just being how they are in that
neighborhood and so i'm just razzing
each other and then in montana it would
it was mostly just me being weird or i'm
sure they said stuff about the way i
looked but i don't really remember
because i mostly just tried to be
friends with everybody
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
would you say you were a popular kid i
mean you were like a
what was your group i mean you you
mentioned like being a goth or like were
you music kid or um did you play sports
i you know it's funny i i did i did it
all i tried to do it all my whole goal
for uh high school because in junior
high i just got so lucky timing-wise i
swear it's like i the the decades that i
got to grow up yeah if i had to choose i
would have chosen that time yeah i
wouldn't have chosen a different time
that's exactly the perfect time for me
to have grown up totally because i got
all the benefits of all the cool stuff
that was happening you know at least
where i was at so yeah but um you know
so the first year i was like well junior
high i saw
16 candles
and i was like oh [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] yeah
you know i was identifying with all the
nerds and the geeks or whatever because
i was drawing starships cutaway views of
starships and like labeling like all the
you know the aft this is where the
fusion reactor you know um and uh like
junior high and i played football in my
last year of junior high because i
wanted to try sports
and uh because i was kind of a chubby
kid
and then in high school i also did
football and my friend john thomas who i
was friends with since junior high
also got into football and my goal
really
you know because then my first my
freshman year the breakfast club came up
so so i was exactly the age of when
those movies came out
those people so i was like in that
world uh you know that was a reflection
that i would apply to my ongoing
existence so who in the breakfast club i
know this is the great thing about the
movie is that there are all those
archetypes are um they realize that they
have a lot more in common and but who
was there one that you
identified with was it would it have
been anthony michael hall or emilio ali
sheedy uh ali sheedy would be is the
type of
well actually
my type of girls that i had crush
crushes on would have been that perfect
mixture
of ali sheedy and molly ringwald uh-huh
like the types of characters that they
played the characters they played claire
and whatever uh her name was um
those are the two because like the
outsider kind of you know kind of shy
but weird yeah and like you know doing
crazy stuff and um but really cute like
yeah
and just like when she pushes the hair
off her face it's like whoa
i know you're like whoa and which is
kind of a cool you know it's cool as a
cool reveal obviously and they were like
now we're now we're making you a square
you know but it's not you know it wasn't
really that but it was just like that's
such a cool thing to see that and
because obviously she's inward she's an
inward personality and doesn't think
that she can fit in but she also has a
strong
take on you know how she feels about you
know classism yes and and then you know
and then molly ringwald
that preppy
you know like everything's just so and
just like the button up klaus blair
like claire she's like but stylish and
classy and and you knew that i don't
know it was just like two personality
types i was like yeah yeah um
but um absolutely yeah
but um i identified mostly with bender
i would have been like a compositive
bender and
maybe a little bit of anthony michael
hall kind of
but with a little bit more jovialness
like i wasn't as like
yeah try another one you know it's like
like like what's wrong claire you know
claire that's a fat girl's name you know
yeah that wasn't my thing yeah he had an
abusive uh and like again when he when
he gets he's clearly got like those
father issues and yeah really hostile um
oh man yeah that
it's so good it holds up i don't know
when the last time you saw it was but i
saw it it does hold up it does hold up
because there's no long duck dong in it
yeah
yeah that's right you know i actually
didn't know 16 i don't know 16 candles
really well no oh really no no i and i
love john hughes we talked about john
he's a lot on the show he comes up all
the time um
i just think his people our age like it
was such a
he's such an important figure i mean he
was making such important stuff uh well
yeah well he's making movies for us yeah
yeah and he really believed that it
wasn't it wasn't just like
it wasn't it wasn't like oh here's a
demographic i think i'll be able to make
movies for that will be attracted to
them he literally
saw himself from the perspective of the
of that age group at that time yeah and
and he gave voice
to teenagers in a way that had never
been given voices before they were taken
seriously as like whole beings that have
a huge range of emotional complications
that they have to deal with right i
never gave him enough credit for that i
never i never understood until i got
older until i
i saw how rare that is to be able to tap
into a
teenage psyche like that and without any
hint of like condescension
no it was like super respectful and
oftentimes like even in pretty in pink
you know she's taking care of her father
yeah you know it's like she has a lot of
responsibility
and she's had to like pull it together
you know and same thing with ducky it's
like you know lower in you know like
lower middle class you know kid or
whatever and it was really about a lot
about classes yeah but but um and just
you know people reacting from that class
perspective but
but yeah otherwise it was like teenagers
were just like i don't want to talk to
you i'm out of here you know and like
like that was like the complexity of
teenagers was like let's party
like ah you look good sharon yeah wish
you looked this good you know like
that's it that's like that's all that's
it that's all teenagers do yeah and
instead he's just like here's a deeply
emotional you know yeah mixed with a
really absurd sense of humor you know
whatever was there was there that in
reggie
in your town in great falls was it was
there did you recognize that class as
classism and that that class's struggle
yeah i mean i did and that's what i
meant that's why i was saying like i
tried all of this [ __ ] in in high school
because my first year i was like i'm
going to be in sports and i want to have
that jock perspective you know so i was
like i'm going to be in sports
and uh
i'm going to get into i think yeah
sports and then i was kind of like a
nothing person like i wasn't really a
particular class i was just like a
weirdo i guess you know maybe i could be
a dork or something
um and then and i wasn't but i was in
football so what position did you play
the dork part
i totally picked and designed everything
about my football experience it was um
my jersey number was 69.
okay
uh
uh my why i play i played
well because like
[Laughter]
two hours later
[Music]
i wish i hadn't asked that
i know that could withstand that sitting
um well no uh 69 and then i played right
guard oh that was the name of a
deodorant all right
that's a tough position too
yeah yeah right guard is like not
it's not the funnest yeah you're just a
wall you're just a movie a wall yeah
you're cons but also constantly um
did you ever get knocked out did you
ever have any injuries oh uh
i didn't i never got concussed i i
definitely
you know what it was for me i i don't
really think i got hurt because my heart
wasn't fully into football it was this
was more like an anthropological
so you weren't committing to the plays i
wasn't committing it i never memorized
the plays oh really and so yeah so what
so basically what happened first of all
uh i the pads i wore like i wore the
regular pads but then because i was so
protective of my hands as a piano player
and a violinist um
i was always very protective of my hands
since i was a little kid you know when
i'd wash dishes i'd be standing on a
stool to wash dishes but i would have my
gloves on because i don't want to get my
hands wet
um i just don't like it when it gets all
pruney it's like um
it's like i don't want that pune uh but
uh
yeah so i would wear i would take uh
ace bandage and i would i would hold a
roll of ace bandage and then i would um
i have a glove on and i would be holding
that and then i would wrap
i'd get like the knuckle pad oh you have
a small pad that you like you know slip
on over so i'd have one there then
another one up here
another one up here and then um yeah so
that would be it and i would be holding
the oh my god sprain wrap so that i'd
have impact resistance so i wouldn't
crush my fingers if i got into a bad
time that's really not tackle but yeah
but it also prevents you from any like
holding penalties you're not able to
grip oh that's actually that's true
that's actually true yeah that's true i
never even thought about that yeah i you
know but i wasn't in the game that much
i wasn't thinking that far ahead
but the funny thing was like you know as
i you know we'd be in the huddle and be
like uh red dog 33
red dog 33 uh and michaels make sure
you're there for that blah blah okay
cool are we we all set and we're gonna
do that on three all right on three got
it hut you know but go hike or whatever
they say huh and then like we go to the
line as we're walking the line i'd be
walking standing walking next to the
nose guard and i'd be like what am i
supposed to do he's like ah
man
just just go forward then go to the
right
oh my god i'd have a panic attack if i
didn't know those plays i oh yeah that's
that you know that's like that's my
whole life as an improviser like that
like even in football which is like so
incredibly structured i was just like oh
no i'll just go for it was that where is
that
that's interesting because it reminds me
of your
musical technique and like the
improvisational element of your
musicality and how you
infuse that into comedy i i like when i
saw you perform i had never seen anybody
like that i'm sure you've heard that a
lot like i you were to me you're a
totally unique
performer did is that how it was that
the genesis of that
did it kind of come from just
doing whatever
yeah i think it did it was definitely a
lot of whateverisms but i definitely had
um you know like in elementary school i
threw a school play i like approached my
principal and was like can i do a school
play you know at uh whatever for
uh whatever you call those things uh
like an assembly specialist a special
assembly yeah like a special assembly um
and so
uh i remember talking to the
the principal about that and then he was
like oh yeah sure again i made it like a
nod about drugs it's like an anti-drug
thing or whatever and so i'm sorry so i
did that but
so that's kind of like a playful thing
that i was you know i was always
conspiring like i had like a
conspiratorial mind i was always trying
to formulate a thing that i wanted to
accomplish or something that i wanted to
do because i loved performing and so
so i was doing that there and then and
then in junior high i did a little bit
of drama and i did speech and debate um
in drawing and and there so that was
kind of a performative yeah and then in
high school
junior year was a junior year
freshman year i joined the drama
team
and uh and i did humorous solo it
competed in humorous solo and that was
me just improvising a bunch of
impersonations you know pop songs for
like 10 minutes in front of judges in a
school in a school room over a weekend
you know for some like parent judges
uh they must have love well how did that
go over do you remember
and and were you at all nervous did you
have any like
fear like anxiety about performing
well i was excited and i was definitely
nervous like in the beginning but you
know i knew i had to do i had to go on i
was there i had to do the thing
um but once i started doing it i saw
that people enjoyed it the nervousness
went away it was definitely more
just
anxious about performing right that's
right that's more the the more thing
like but you know i also got to see like
what i do now with stand-up comedy you
know um uh when you're there on a
line-up night or whatever it's i was
watching all the actors so all the
performers the people i was competing
against i loved watching what they had
to do yeah you know and then also
obviously seeing like how good are they
doing like will i stand a chance right
but but i had always so i did it
improvisationally then you know and then
in junior high or
sophomore year i was
student government i was really i was in
the student government so i was like
i'll be in student government try to
like get on that popular kids you know
thing or whatever and then i would get
invited to the popular kids parties or
whatever but um
but i was also doing drama so i was
doing drama but it was also an orchestra
and i was in ap art
and so i was doing a ton of [ __ ] because
i was a very social person
and then when i discovered
my friends fish and beef the summer of
sophomore year they were from the other
school on the other side of town cmr and
uh they were told like new wavers and
you know and my friend john was like you
know had me listening to the smiths and
the smithereens and cabaret voltaire
revolting cox alien sex fiend ministry
all that [ __ ] back in junior high
and then i was listening to that during
freshman year and then junior year or uh
sophomore year and then at that summer i
met
uh those two people and they were like
in the bao house and using the band
she's ah cure kind of more punctual and
then no more punk like punk new wave and
goth yeah post punk punk new wave goth
[ __ ] and uh an industrial and you know
and then all their friends were like
super hot like everybody was like it was
like it was like the most they hit it
was like the lost boys you know okay
like yes
it was kind of like that
that was kind of like my crew my crew
was like lost boys meets sid nancy
meets uh just kind of like weirdo
outsider artist like
it was crazy how everybody was just
gorgeous like it was stupid come with us
michael
i know come with us michael
come on come on
you want the rice
it's like what those are just not rice
you're eating
oh god i i remember thinking that that
was my conception of la and anyone from
la for the longest time was from the
lost boys i was like oh they're all like
super cool and they're you know just way
ahead of us socially and everyone looks
beautiful
and but weird and most of them are
vampires
like a very severe
thing going on yeah somewhere yeah that
that was definitely i remember my friend
chelsea she when we'd hang out sometimes
we party and she would have lingerie on
with a clear raincoat
over it for her outfit and crazy like
lipstick and smeared eye shadow
and
it was sick and my friend ren was like
pasty white like crazy pasty white but
like would wear this crazy blood red
lipstick and had this weird asymmetrical
haircut and wore like you know like late
18th century style clothing or whatever
you always like steampunk
well not steampunk but like uh more like
hor you know like horror movies that
always take place like in some house and
there's a ghost from like the late 1800s
or the mid-1800s like standard horror
stories we get like eight of them a year
now um
that more that more like that gothic
like older okay gothic like buttoned up
um
kind of yes thank you yeah victorian and
kind of like [ __ ] up which reminds me
by the way i was i was in sweden with a
swedish friend and i was like
would you call it the victorian area was
it was this around during the victory
and she's like well that's not our queen
oh yeah
and then i was like oh interesting i
would never write about that it'd be
like the gustavian era
yeah yeah yeah whoever that yeah whoever
that was yeah it would be like but i
mean we know but like it's just kind of
funny but um yeah but all my friends
were just
they were just they were awesome wow
weirdos well that makes sense because
you definitely have that you have a very
so i think of it as a unique style but
um now i'm imagining you just completely
uh
well i have that
no no no no no i mean i had this picture
uh let's see reggie's showing me his
phone oh my god he's showing me oh
that's you i almost said which one's you
uh
reggie showed me a picture of high
school what
you have completely shaved head almost
like a um
well there's something almost like like
like an iroquois indian uh native
american american yeah look like a
warrior wow that's
intense that was back in the day too
like
close to patrick mahomes look but
more severe
yeah yeah it's like uh
yeah you were even like you know the
girl from bow wow wow yes
yes like that shave thing it was a very
like tribal punk you know yeah it's very
like the warriors or something
yeah warriors road runner
uh not road runner
the road warrior yeah
yeah you know the road warrior that
movie with mel gibson and coyote
and mel gibson was always like here like
the coyote was always trying to get mel
gibson
[Laughter]
um that's that makes a lot of sense and
then were you like during that time when
you found that group and
you found your footing there were you
like [ __ ] football was it that i imagine
football became like am i gonna do that
i mean
i think with football i i just i it kind
of ran its course and uh i was you know
i wanted to know what it was like and
then that was kind of it you know but i
think um
what was it uh
i remember that uh just before school
was uh was was going to end in my
sophomore year
the i got called like from class the
coach wanted to see me
and i remember like being in the middle
of classes like uh the coach wants to
see it i'm like oh [ __ ]
but the kids were like why yeah
yeah i look cool
i was like [ __ ] but what
so um so i went down it was like his
offices were like in the uh under the
school like in kind of like this boiler
room like there's like locker rooms
very krugery um and he basically he
showed me
a couple pieces of footage
of me playing football which would be so
great if i could find
i would i mean come on you know 69 r
watts you know run in place
um i mean come on uh but did he when you
were like 169 did he bought was he like
what
did he balk at that no i don't think
anybody did because i can't remember how
we chose it it might have been like on a
you know like a like a a sheet or
something like that i don't know i don't
totally remember but uh
but they gave it to me yeah it was
pretty rad um but no he was he was down
there and he was he showed me these
things and he basically showed me the
footage and there was like one play that
i did where i was like running like
right next to the running back and there
was like someone goes about to tackle
him and i pushed him off at the last
minute he scored a touchdown you know so
i got to experience one of those oh cool
but
he was like uh when you know we need you
you know we need you to be in football
next year or whatever and i was like
uh-huh uh-huh and he's like it's gonna
be really good for you or i don't know
whatever you know whatever he was saying
it's just trying to get me to play
football and i was like uh-huh
uh-huh and then you know i i left and i
was like no that's not gonna happen yeah
i i was i mean it was it was honor yeah
yeah it must be flattering too i mean i
i yeah i've always funny because i my
experience was that i always want that
was my fantasy to be able to play play
football just to suit up just to where i
was into all the
the optics of it you got to do
everything i mean that is cool you had
to what a diverse like high school
experience well
i mean it was i feel really lucky you
know because i we had such amazing
adventures and i'm writing an audio auto
autobiography right now and working with
a writer right now while we're talking
talking yeah oh wow uh you can take a
break to me um
the present you seem to me
well
i don't know i mean i mean i told you i
did a lot of stuff in high school
that changed now okay that's right and i
haven't seen your fingers
that's true i've been actually i've been
my legs have been um paddling a potter's
wheel
and i've just been like slowly shaping a
boss but i'm not looking at it because
it's an experiment like oh what how good
can i be without looking that's amazing
yeah i know thanks um when is that are
you how far into the process are you
uh we're at a we're at a spot now where
we're gonna um
kind of look at what we have so far and
kind of create start to create a little
bit of a structure for what we're going
to do with the information because right
now it's just been like recounting
things and him asking questions to kind
of focus in and i'm sure this will be in
it
but just as a little teaser when you
moved to seattle you moved through it at
and was it to go to school was it to
study music was it to just to be in
seattle
it was just to finally be able to [ __ ]
yeah i was just like i just wanna you
know
yeah [ __ ] is encouraged in seattle
but i didn't know what it was i just
knew the word i didn't know what it
actually was attached to it's like i
just know i need to [ __ ] it's like do
you know what that is i don't know is it
bagels
you innocently say that at job
interviews yeah i just came here to [ __ ]
yeah and uh i just heard this yell is
great for [ __ ] and um
sound garden
um no i i
yeah 18 i moved to seattle you know it
was because i i did try out for drama
school american music and dramatic
academy in in new york
yes
and there was there were tryouts in
chicago and i drove out there with my
friend wally who i did a humorous duo
with in competitive drama in high school
and um and we drove out there with his
uncle his uncle drove us out there and
then he auditioned he had a piece
prepared i didn't have a piece prepared
i was just gonna you know just go for it
and uh
and i did that and they were like uh you
need to have a piece
so we can see if you can [ __ ] act
um and uh and then i so i didn't make it
and then he but he got in and so i told
myself well if i don't make it there
then i'm gonna go to seattle
um because also
uh soundgarden is there oh this is an
amazing band yeah and so i just heard
that there's good stuff going on in
music so i might as well move over there
and then i applied for the art institute
of seattle
and got in for their audio engineering
program
and that's what got me to seattle and uh
yeah and was the music i mean that's
come up a lot people from seattle joel
mchale i'm trying to remember who else
bunch of people from
seattle and i've talked to carrie
brownstein about slater kinney's early
days there and oh right did you know
those girls did you oh yeah i totally
know carrie very well yeah i bet yeah
and not not when they were doing their
thing but like later okay uh and what
was what was that like for you what was
your experience uh was it just was it
overwhelming
did you
did you fit right in
i mean
seattle was so different back then you
know 19 i moved there in 1990 the summer
of 90. wow and
it was
you know it was just a it was a small
town
it was a small city and
uh you know at night there was barely
any cars moving around you know it was
like a kind of a quiet town
and there were only i think there at the
time in 1990 there were probably only
two places to play music officially like
like a music venue and a kind of
makeshift music venue that's right
somebody told me and i'm tr i'm
struggling to remember why it had yet to
be built up it was um it was not a
desirable place to live and there was a
reason for that uh i don't know if it
was a post-industrial thing or um
yeah maybe there's a tough jobs market
or something like that yeah logging
shortage
yeah logging shortage
although microsoft came up there right
that's right
so well maybe that was responsible then
for the boom
yes it was 100 yeah they set up in
redmond and uh you know a lot of stuff
started creeping in but in the early 90s
you know
i i mean i was
i guess i was in the audio engineering
program and then i was in a band that i
moved into a band house with two other
musicians and we were in a band and had
this band house would rehearse in the
basement and um
like way up on aurora like 98th in
aurora which is like way up up that that
huge street
and um
so i was playing music i didn't and i
saw some music but i wasn't of age yet
you know so uh when i turned 21
yeah when i turned 21 i was still
playing that band but then i started
seeing bands you know like would go out
and see a band somewhere and then i then
i just got into shitloads of bands and i
moved to capitol hill which was kind of
like the early williamsburg of new york
you know at that time and a lot of like
like shady [ __ ] everywhere you know
heroin users junkies and punkers and
gutter punks and musicians and like
artists struggling artists and stuff
like that low income and were playing
with this band during that time i was a
little bit we never really played i
don't think we ever played in a club
which is kind of weird but we we just
played like out we'd get a rent a
generator and like play like at uh
um prospect park like under the old uh
post-industrial pipe uh installation or
whatever um and maybe some house a lot
of house parties oh and
reg what was the thing that
kind of blew it all open at what point
did it become did you go from
these more localized uh groups and and
venues to
being on comedy bang bang for example or
or um
doing anything that people can now see
really like where i would get where
we've gotten something of no national
note it would have been
well first the andy kaufman award
um
that was kind of like the first big
thing
that happened um and i i did edinboro
for three years and did pretty well
there um got like a lot of good reviews
there and then um
and then kristen shaw kind of pushed me
into
um
applying to you know for or trying out
for the andy kaufman award
and uh and i did that and then i won it
and
that was like really amazing and then
maybe a couple years after that
uh conan yeah the conan tour ah so cool
i and i i've always wanted to graduate
when you do you ever
are those questions you asked on gordon
are they purely from the top of your
head are they do you
ever think about those beforehand
no i don't i just i just i'm too lazy
but i uh i have you ever gotten stuck
have you ever been like stoned or
something where you like and you're just
like uh you just like haven't somebody
really intimidating they've been close
they've been close moments sometimes
because it's not necessarily about the
the person that i get intimidated by i
definitely get excited by certain people
yeah and i want to ask the right
question and generally like throughout
the interview i'll be thinking about a
question okay for that that type of
person so and i'll have like kind of a
loose idea about what i want to ask okay
and then it'll just come out in the
moment you know but um
so
i'll get excited or kind of nervous
about like i really want to ask this
person but should i ask them like a
serious question or should i ask them
like something really absurd or silly
you know they seem like
well the interview they were talking
about some serious stuff so let's just
lighten it up you know
um
but that's like the max max prep
has anyone been like
put off by it has anyone been like uh
like um oh yeah oh yeah some people some
people are like they don't know what to
say
they don't know what to say and
sometimes what they say is kind of comes
off a little
mean or condescending but i don't think
they mean it that way but it's just them
reacting in the moment and you know like
sharon stone was i was saying something
like
i think the question was
uh do you
uh do you like to you know work out and
stuff like that or something you know
and she she's like
yes but you don't
and i was like oh
okay
thanks
and then uh and then i and i remember
the producers going like i don't think
she meant it that way i think she meant
it more like um
like do you
oh that really charming guy who's that
guy who's friends with uh james who's
he's like super handsome and like
oh ben ben yes yes the show runner yeah
the showrunner yeah that's who i was
doing an impression of yet yeah oh
terrible impression
no but he's so positive and like
charming he's i can see him
i know yeah of course of course because
they want to smooth it out i was just
like ah like it just like was very like
sad making immediately well that's like
wow yeah i bet i bet it's like brought
you right back to like
oh
and especially like of all the people to
do it's like sharon stone
i know yeah oh no i'm sorry not sharon
stone jane fonda
well still
that's because that's why i was asking
the exercise question oh right oh yeah
the jet the
yeah yeah you know aerobics
yeah my mom was so into that stuff
we have a lightning round oh yeah i
thought you might have fun with um
oh good yeah oh sorry oh sorry here it's
more like this i mean this isn't being
recorded but okay you ready
it's amazing
wow i've never seen anyone do an
impression of lightning
yeah i mean it wasn't
in in that particular case because the
the thunder was synced with each of the
lightning strikes
it would have meant that i would have
been dead right because it would have
yeah
that's true it was not anywhere in the
distance
i mean like hey justin justin justin
check out this impression of lightning
[Laughter]
which is so ironic he died doing a
lightning round he died from lightning
during
the lightning round it was so good
uh what impressions did you do is it
you're such a great voice and i'm you
had mentioned you do you did impressions
in high school who were you doing was it
all musical based or did you do um
you know like ronald reagan or anything
yeah
well
um
no i know who i did a lot is uh
unfortunately but bill cosby
[Music]
well no back then no one knew i mean no
one knew no of course no but i mean i
was i mean i was a huge fan of bill
cosby you know um yeah but uh
yeah i did i did an impression of him
and i'm trying to think if i did anybody
else i did fat albert oh that yeah you
did that that was good a little bit
scooby-doo
oh scooby-doo
were you aunt will you answer this
joyce
that's like g-scoob like i don't know
that's so good
anyways but you want me to answer
questions yeah will you answer this as
shaggy um uh shaggy what is your most
commonly used emoji
like uh i don't know
like they didn't have emojis i guess in
the sense
no no you no i think it's i think
because it's fully imaginary we can
let's [ __ ] time
come
on through
uh no what was it what was the question
do you
if do you use emojis often are you doing
um
what is your like go-to what do you find
really useful which one let's see
if i'm looking here uh i find
uh
[Music]
hello
okay there we go i use the the deep red
heart
a lot deep red heart oh yeah cause
there's like a lighter red heart that
has like a little bit more reflective
top to it like like a little reflection
on that oh yeah yeah or a shine on top
and i like the more matte yes darker red
heart it's like more it's just got more
gravity to it yeah um i also use the
pink double heart oh okay
i use the
kissy face these are all blood oh sure
i do the double tear laughing
the
laughing with just one
bead of sweat
oh that's laughing
yeah yeah cause it's like ah kind of
like a nervous like
you know that kind of thing
um yeah i use a smiley face with rosy
cheeks
i too uh
crossed fingers
in my skin tone
um i do thumbs up i do robot a hundred
percent apparently camera flashing
waving hand
uh regular red heart with the shiny
stuff on it uh race car
and um oh apparently i've used a top hat
recently if you could be a professional
athlete reg what sport would you play
and do you follow do you follow sports
still do you follow football
no i don't i i don't i i watch uh
parkour really there's like there's a
there's a what are you watching
well parker there's parkour videos you
know like people just doing parkour
where they have like challenges they're
trying to like you know do a stunt or
something like that and then then
there's an actual game that's played uh
i think it's called
chaser evader i think is is i don't know
what it's formally called but i think it
might even be called tag or something
but it's uh two parkour artists on
different uh
athletes on different teams and they
start at jason or kitty corner from each
other in this big square that has a
bunch of kind of like jungle jimmy
structures yeah
and then they start the time and there's
like 20 seconds
uh on the clock and the one person who's
the chaser has to try to
um tag the evader oh that's cool there's
a game there's a network show like that
a little bit uh america not ninja
warrior but like it's kind of like that
yeah it's kind of like that but it's
more like uh just
parkour and i think it's just very
simple
chase chase you got 20 seconds and like
oh you tagged him he's like oh he's out
there's a point to the team but um so i
watched that and then i also watched a
strong man oh repetitions really yeah
yeah cause it's just insane watching a
dude pick up a thousand and six pounds
yeah deadlifting yeah a thousand six
pounds god in heaven
the mountain that's the guy who did it
who did it the mountain oh well it makes
sense yeah but um anyways uh so yeah no
sports no um did you watch the bachelor
anymore now now i'm having memories of
watching the best oh yeah i remember you
were really into it yeah when we first
met and uh no oh yeah you had watched i
tried to turn you on to it yeah you did
you did a good job but i just i couldn't
no um if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life what would it
be
your go-to like you're you're stoned
you're you've got a good movie oh [ __ ]
and no consequences no consequences it's
a vacuum
man favorite snack favorite snack god
i'm trying to think um
probably
yeah i would say probably tiny tiny
burgers
what are tiny what do you mean like like
white castle like like no not that tiny
but like you know like mcdonald's
cheeseburger size brand oh yeah yeah but
but they would be made of it would be a
plant-based burger oh um because there's
a there's a there's a burger place here
in town called virgo guys uh-huh
and um they make the most perfect
plant-based burger i think they use
beyond patty but i like the beyonce
i do too yeah it's really i do too i
like it better than impossible
um possible kind of sometimes can upset
my stomach but um anyways i would
probably do that like but just you know
burger is like that big like okay yeah
like spiders like a little bigger than
the sliders bigger than the slider
that's the or the original burger size
when brownies were first invented um
that was the original size now we've got
these monsters but yeah that's true um
burgers burger yeah it's just like
burger with a v
burger guys i'll be out there soon i'm
going to try that uh oh yeah what's your
favorite movie sequel of all time
sequel um
uh empire strikes back oh yeah yeah
that's the first movie i remember
watching in the theater
um i have still have like little flashes
of remember
holding onto my dad's hand during the oh
yeah yeah oh man right i mean that first
time when you saw like they showed the
shot of the uh imperial walkers way in
the distance through the binoculars yes
it's kind of like shaky and they're like
kind of zooming in a little bit and then
you see like what the [ __ ] is that thing
it's just like
walking just slowly or whatever and it's
just they're just slowly advancing very
slowly and they're like in emergency
mode on the base you know whatever
getting great and that abominable
snowman just i'll never forget that how
freaking that was just a quick shot of
it like that
oh yeah i know
you barely saw it yeah i know that's
what i loved about it yeah it was a
thing called
it was just cloth creature what was it
just
hoth creepy hot creature i think yeah i
think i had the toy and you could kind
of like pull the hand back the arm back
yes yes i remember the taunton that had
the yes stomach with the splitness so
you could put luke inside of it yes yeah
i would put all different yeah i was
like well you could put any of the
characters inside it yeah it turns out
it's not just the one that's on the
cover of the toy
um
that's when i knew i was gonna be an
actor yeah for sure what's your um go-to
karaoke song
kevin okay um i don't do it very i don't
do it see it's okay um i don't do it
very often but uh when i do i usually do
um
is this love by white snake oh wow i'd
love to hear that yeah yeah i love that
song yeah oh that'd be fun uh who was
your first celebrity crush
celebrity crush i guess would it would
it be um
it might have been molly ringwald
actually because i saw her first because
of 16 candles oh right but right um i
would yeah because i can't really i'm
trying to remember aside from like you
know poster girls like kathy ireland
yeah like that you know which that's not
really or you know i guess
because then you didn't really know them
like you're molly i didn't know them but
like yeah they were people um
no i think if i really go back i would
probably say
marianne oh yeah
oh did she just pass away yeah she did
yeah yes
yeah all right she was she was she was
awesome in that everybody was like
ginger and i was like nah man marianne
yeah yeah i love that a day is confused
uh now i'm remembering that scene where
they're like the professor was sexy
yeah
um
if you had you have tattoos do you have
tattoos you do
i have no tattoos yeah would you uh if
you were to get one what would it be
uh
you know it's a good question well you
know back in the day when i was
considering getting a tattoo which the
mid-90s in seattle it was very amazing
that i made it through oh yeah oh my god
everybody was like tattoos and piercings
yeah like that was like a huge deal
huge deal especially in seattle but um
i i had the idea of doing a sleeve
uh that
was the uh
schematics of
uh uh a roland uh
i'm thinking of a oh sorry a juno
yeah a juno synthesizer so um
yeah and uh or or a tr tr808 like a 808
machine drum machine but just like the
schematics of it in white ink oh whoa so
just be white and really thin lines and
a schematic and just kind of go from the
top of the shoulder to the you know
bottom of the bicep and what uh why
didn't you do it was it just like this
is too much it was too ambitious i just
[ __ ] couldn't no um i
i just i just wasn't into like having
something permanently i know me
i know
uh what is your favorite fruit a nice
ripe piece of
what
you know i don't like fruit but really
yeah i but i know fruits
i like berries
okay but i i don't i don't know what it
is about like big fruit you know like
fruit and it's usually a little bit
bigger usually i mean a lychee that's
not that you know but uh i don't like
the texture usually
and fruit is too sweet for me oh okay it
tastes like i'm just eating sugar who
and who would you want to play you in in
your biopic reg
oh man um i don't know who could play
you except for you
i don't you know i think it would be
like an un uh discovered yeah because i
can't really yeah
i can't wait there was a kid that played
a young version high school version of
me in um
a music video that i did for my song uh
if you're [ __ ]
and that's because because it opens with
like him and a girl in the 80s in
montana and uh and they're in a truck or
something like that or a car
and
they're like you see like the truck like
moving around they're like like they're
doing like weird moves and stuff like
that and they're like wait wait wait
wait wait
are we [ __ ]
and she's like i guess so and then the
song starts
um and uh but
uh the kid who played me like looked
kind of close to me oh really so i would
it'd probably have used someone we have
to find oh i gotta see that um lightning
round so quick so quick uh uh who's your
favorite simpsons character
oh [ __ ] you know i never watched the
simpsons oh what about the muppets we
used to ask about the muppets yeah the
muppets that's the way to go um
my favorite muppet man
guys there's so many i love but uh i
would say maybe
maybe doctor teeth oh yeah yeah i'm
trying to remember how he went yeah was
he did you ever have like a like a leon
red bone yeah that's right yeah yeah
it's kind of like
all right like you guys one two three
yeah yeah that's good
he he was he was cool i mean i love so
many of the muppets but i love janine uh
you're jasmine
oh like oh my god yeah yeah it's kind of
like a like a
like a belly
she was like a valley girl but she's
also kind of like joni mitchell a little
bit yes totally she's like a valley
mitchell
yeah yeah
yeah oh my god um dogs or cats reggie
cats
yes okay i love meow heads do you have a
cat no meow heads yet but oh he's gonna
get him yeah
yeah sorry meow heads or ruff-ruff heads
yeah yeah oh
oh
meows
yeah i
i love uh i love them i just think
they're so cool and they take care of
themselves and they're smart and they
you know i don't have to it's basically
i don't have to take care of it right
they're they're good with they're good
like for lazy friends yeah yeah uh
beetles are the rolling stones
beetles are wrong you know that's so
hard because i never really listened to
either of them oh i really like the
songs that you hear out all the time
yeah yeah it's impossible not to ever
listen to them i was the kind of i was a
wings guy oh
really
wow okay that makes sense
if i had to choose if i had to choose i
would probably say
the beatles
um seinfeld and friends are both on tv
which one do you watch
i've watched seinfeld and friends it's a
great show
what's going on here
uh there's some hijinks going on in this
impossibly way too large apartment um
no um
i would say god seinfeld i didn't really
watch seinfeld a lot so but i did watch
friends so i'd have to say friends okay
there's a kramer here for somebody which
one of you is
friends with craig
is it cramer or joey
because because you know cramer's the
kramer's the kramer and joey's the
kramer of friends yeah yeah or kramer
or is phoebe i don't know
well because well because uh
uh joey was always uh
rushing he was like barging in oh okay
okay he was a barger
i don't really know friends well he was
debarge
um
he was to barge and
courtney cows was the brat
yes
buddy i know we're over we're five
minutes over but um i could talk to you
for another two two hours and five
minutes i it's so fun
yeah you're the best man it'd be great
to see i can't wait to to be out there
and uh when this is all over ah
concerts concerts yeah i know i can't
i'm gonna be i'm gonna like be
always out of here yeah i bet um well
it's good to see you and thanks for
doing this this was fun
[Music]
so that's just how that just happened
happened um oh you're doing like a
spikoli no there there's like a little
or a keanu
is it two kills oh no is it two he's got
there's a little bit of l.a uh i didn't
really know reggie watts at all i didn't
know his comedy i knew he did beatboxing
stuff but i i really only knew him
as
someone who works on the james oh really
yeah so i knew him as and he's
he's strange on that show he's funny but
like he does that question at the end
but he's very like
he's kind of introspective and shy
seeming and i know that's like part of
the shtick but
but i had no idea oh really that he was
like this he's like so smart oh he's so
fun so funny he's just he's fun to like
he's like um he's like a fascinating
yeah and he's he's also like a hilarious
hilarious like a
he's like a jazz uh conversationalist
you know like a jazz comedic jazz i
don't want to overstate this
but i think it was one of my favorite uh
episodes we've done it's like i put it
right up there with um the new girl guys
and the new guys the new guys and jake
johnson and alec baldwin is one of my
favorites well because it's
accommodating really funny yeah it's
it's a combination of reggie obviously
he's just so quick and like can kind of
he's so fluid in his time he can he can
kind of go anywhere and uh and i'm
comfortable with him i know him well
enough to be like yeah you had a really
good rapport like i can't believe i
can't remember how i'm very you know the
more i've noticed this about you not to
get in your head but uh i'm gonna get in
your head
when you're comfortable with someone
you say um
less like significantly huh
yeah because you're not searching for
the perfect word the perfect way of
saying like a more impressive sounding
word
yeah i mean nothing again i thought you
had a really interesting talk with jane
goodall for example but uh a lot of a
lot of bumps yeah that's funny yeah
but with him almost no arms ah um
um
yeah that's interesting i hope that
didn't get in your head
no moving forward no and
i think it is something to be i'm aware
i think i know that i that i stammer
more and i search more for yeah of
course i
um
yeah he i
now i'm just trying to think of how i
met him for some reason it's like who
cares but i remember seeing him for the
first time perform uh on the conan tour
when conan was had left nbc and was
doing his
uh right before he went to tbs and he
was doing this tour and reggie opened
for him reggie was his opening act and
he would do the sounds and the
beatboxing it was hard to i
i wouldn't be able to see it you got to
see it because it's hard to even like do
like a one-liner for it like i wouldn't
know how to encapsulate like oh reggie
even to say he's a stand-up or he
incorporated music performer he's a
performer when he said he won i'd never
heard of this award but the andy kaufman
award yeah that makes sense it makes
sense yeah yeah he's got like how do you
explain andy kaufman right exactly they
have a similar
offbeat
but even that it's like i know that's
such a like cliche he's like even when
you talk about new girl you mentioned
the new girl guys it was they they
always describe that as like quirky and
offbeat and
um but reggie is like he's just so
unique that doesn't do him justice you
know he's so unique that
every single one of his lightning round
answers
shocked me you know what i mean yeah
it's in a funny yeah in a funny way
how great was that i forgot how funny
that was with your favorite snacks
he goes probably tiny burgers
that's so funny
because he's also part of reggie is like
he's just got such a great
look like his unique look i mean like
he's not with his hair yeah
and nothing against cats but
it's funny that he aggressively answered
cats yes you know of course for sure yes
that surprised me too yeah he seems i
mean we've talked about like
the idea of like confidence and
insecurities come up a lot and i'm
there's something about reggie that is
he's a type of confident person and very
honest person that is um
just so different than the other
confident people like we we've talked
about we've like
lauded you know like mcconaughey or like
i mean there's such but he has a similar
type of confidence i think well i'm sure
i mean who knows why anyone truly is the
way they are but i i think in his case
there's an element of um
diversity in his upbringing yeah that
played a problem not just
racially but yeah but you know socially
trying to fit in with you know being
brought up uh in europe and then split
in time between montana and cleveland
and uh and just
trying everything you know in high
school he talked about doing like
playing football and music and drama and
debate and he just tried everything yeah
so he has this like this rich tapestry
of experiences to draw from that have
all come together to make a truly unique
adult yes and he's like that as an
artist too he's like i'm gonna do a
little bit of this and did sprinkle in a
little like he's like that excuse me
when you talk to him he's he can kind of
go anywhere and he's got
he's into so many different things i i
there's there's a curiosity about him
that um is so
appealing and how great is reggie's
voice too i mean you just have to say
he's like i'm like yeah could not be
more impressed with that person i know
that person yeah he's
truly one of a kind and
and just now i'm like eager to look up
his oh you should he's special and his
startup routine oh it's the best he's
great he's
really fun and he tries things and like
he if it does if it goes a little south
it's kind of part of the fun you know
he's one of those guys it's just you
like just so quick on his feet yeah yeah
yeah he
um
that's why in part it's so fun to hear a
conversation with him because
he's nimble he's nimble yeah and it's
and his uh
and like there's never any point where
it's like what are we talking about next
and like how do i transition to this
topic it just flowed like a river yeah
you like in montana yeah river runs
through it i love that book yeah me too
and the movie is great you both have to
love the book and the movie of a river
runs through it
god damn that movie is really good uh
what do you think of when maybe
yes um
or the book like what what's the what
does it remind you of i remember what
time in your life
oh high school yeah mr mr wallace oh
yeah he mr that was his favorite book
english teacher uh barry well a great
english teacher yeah amazing and uh and
there's there was a lyricism it also
makes me think of try because i used to
try to fly fish myself like i was i
loved that movie so much and i i
romanticized like oh i want to be able
to do that those shots of them on the is
it the missouri river fly fishing um
which so i'm part of it's probably brad
pitt it was like
something like gorgeous and they're like
dab with the water
off his face holding a like beautiful
like rainbow trout and
but um it's hard to get more beautiful
than brad pitt and
yeah yeah i think that was waiting in
the water
peak brad pitt
yeah some people would say fight club
but i would say a river runs through it
i agree with that yeah you don't both
have to think that brad pitt was more
gorgeous and river runs through it
uh yeah man but i tried to fly fly
fishing's really hard and it's something
i want to
i aspire to do one day like in my older
years reggie said something that i
completely agreed with about fishing or
you just reminded me
he said
and maybe i misunderstood him but i
thought he said he really
likes fishing but he doesn't like
catching fish yes i identify i totally
agree i don't like pulling a fish off a
hook i know but i like the process of
sitting and being patient and waiting i
don't love the catching part this is
what's great about reggie reggie i'm
thinking of these things it's like oh my
god we've had all these unique people
different people on the show reggie
could like hang with any of them can't
you see him just fitting in and being
able to like
just flow with i think it's it's pretty
easy to say that he's our most unique
guest oh yeah right
i'm thinking but hard to out unique him
no
no i can't
uh yeah no i know uh let's read a letter
okay great uh it's in the printer behind
you oh whoa yes i printed it out cool
i love this i old school i hate going to
my phone all the time but we shouldn't
print too much because it's bad for the
environment bad for the environment from
kimberley southward
southward maybe south south that's how
this introduction to the letter is gone
southward
um the subject thank you for more than
you know well
dear justin and christian i'd like to
take a moment to say thank you both from
the very bottom of my heart you have no
idea but you kept me sane and on a more
even keel at a time i truly needed it
most i guess i should clarify things a
bit i am an in-home caregiver and
companion as such i assist elderly
people with whatever they require to
complete their daily tasks
it can be boring to some but i love it
and find it so fascinating anyone can
read a history book but to listen to
someone who has lived it and can tell
with the books and tell what the books
can't is amazing
agreed i've totally agreed what
i see that's noble work to me that is
like a life
like that's people go on
about what they do on social media and
stuff and like brags that is
agree again yeah
back to kimberly i do love my job and
feel blessed to be part of their lives
lately though it's become more hospice
care than companion care that's where
you two come in i found your podcast
back in october 2020 and that's about
the time that the 98 year old lady i'd
been working with for about a year began
to decline in health i'd spent an
average of 50 plus hours a week with her
wow for that year
and i've grown to care for her deeply
watching her decline weighed very
heavily on my heart as did watching her
granddaughter lose one of the most
important people in her world it's
heartbreaking well
kimberly we can relate yeah
i would put i would put in one earbud
just one so i could hear her if she
wanted or needed me and would play your
podcast i would smile and quietly laugh
while completing tasks or listen in my
car
on my way home to my own family and feel
a little bit lighter and be better able
to and better able to face whatever
comes next
thank you for being there in a time that
i really needed it even if you didn't
know
man is that nice to hear
the obvious connection and love that you
share is like a healing bomb
it's a tough one for me
bomb b-a-l-m yeah not a bom not a
hydrogen bomb it serves as a lovely
reminder that even though life is short
it keeps going and joy can be found even
in times of pain please don't ever stop
sharing this gift thank you so very much
well
thank god damn thank you kimberly isn't
that so nice um
[Music]
now a little something lighter okay
would you rather yawn yawn that never
felt completed so you always feel like
you have to yawn
or would you rather have a mildly itchy
ear that was never satisfied oh man is
that good
both of those things are mildly itchy
ear
inside or outside do you think i'm in
lobe or inside inside i imagine my
answer is
easy wait wait wait let me think about
it
it's a good question but my answer is
mildly itchy here you'd rather that yeah
i'm different really yeah because i
it sounds really uncomfortable not to be
able to complete a yawn
all the time think about it all the time
but
i rarely yawn
and you said that so proudly i rarely
yeah i'm not proud of it but it's i for
one rarely you know in fact especially
lately because i've been pretty good
about
going to bed before i get too tired you
know so i don't like reach the point of
being exhausted i bet so many people are
like wow [ __ ]
you with kids no i know well i don't
have kids yeah yeah um
i'm not gonna apologize for not having
kids
uh
and
but but if this if i had to pick that
one i would just make sure i would put
even more effort into avoiding yawns
i'd make sure i was more awake yeah
that's true i guess you could and the
itchy ear you can't control your
nightmare it's i haven't you ever had it
mildly each year i hate it yeah it's not
i can't believe you picked that actually
the more i think about it well i i can
well you know what maybe now i'm
thinking like yeah mildly each year
isn't bad maybe because i've satisfied
the edge
of course yeah to always have an itch
that can't be scratched that sounds like
a nightmare to me i feel i feel like
pearl our parents have a dog named pearl
who's max's maybe mother yeah max is
either mother or lover they were found
together just for context to clarify
they were found together in the streets
of la um
and i feel we didn't set them up in a
romantic situation yeah okay
uh that's a good one though yeah oh
there's another one oh would you rather
cry and
oh my god that's amazing but we've had
this one similar to this this is a great
one would you rather cry and say mommy
every time you climax or boy or give a
thunderous fart with every erection
oh boy haven't we had one like this like
weird
climaxes uh mommy mommy cry inside i
would fart
yeah yeah because
whoever was around to
you'd have to say you'd have to explain
it would be funny i mean here's my
here's the problem with that one the big
problem as far as i can see
is that it would be
funny
and it would and it being funny would
potentially ruin
the mood yeah and so i think eventually
if it happened long enough yeah it would
just stop being funny and it would just
be something that happened so so whoever
you were so the mood so the mood would
maintain your lover would have to get
that used to it yeah thunderous fart
yeah but i think i think that's easier
to get used to for someone else
it's weird and but but one is just a
physiological thing well let me and one
is like an emotional it would because i
mean yeah because it would make the
person you are with
and you
not want to climax as nearly as much and
like kind of be afraid of it
and so then like all the stuff that
the erection's no good to you it's like
leading up to that because
stuff leading up to that sort of be like
tainted
pun intended
wow
that's a good one though that is again
an easy answer but uh tough good good
good one yeah uh and then she says kim
really says my superpower it's also
funny that kimberly this like sweet
hospice oh my goodness
i love the first half of the letter
compared to the second half she's great
i mean what if you're well-rounded yes
yes she is like our guest today like
reggie my superpower would be to know
where everything lost is located and the
ability to know this is back to kimberly
my superpower would be to know where
everything lost is located and the
ability to know ability to oh boy and
the ability to know the motives of why
they are where they are
oh yeah that's a good one good one it
doesn't do much for other people yeah
but i
yeah but um i also don't lose things
that frequently you know we were so
catholic
yeah i know but think about when you do
and it's like so frustrating frustrating
we're so you both have to be frustrated
by losing things occasionally so we were
so catholic growing up that like
my mother would always she'd lose things
all the time remember i mean like she'd
be and she'd be like oh god and always
be like
like stressful and like anxiety and uh
she'd say pray to saint anthony's saint
anthony the patron saint of lost [ __ ] i
wonder how sh
yeah that's how he's described on his
like plaque in the vatican the patriots
saying lost [ __ ]
um
i wonder how he became that the patron i
have i've looked i used to be really
into why certain saints become the
patron saint of things that was before
you discovered girls right uh thank you
again for all who i wonder who the
patron saint of girls are
which saints maybe st justin um
you know i want i i think like i was
just like god to have a saint on the
show would be amazing but i just
realized
yeah saying good all right i think
that's as close as we're gonna come at
that's as close as anyone could come to
being dare i say grandma jody yeah
i think so two saints on the show not
bad uh thank you again for all that you
share um well thank you kimberly uh what
a great letter sincerely kimberly
southward from ash north carolina cool
yeah um thanks kimberly and what great
work you're doing and i'm so glad we get
to be a part of that
helping you through that work getting
you you know entertaining you and thanks
again to reggie god what a what a fun
episode i know this is a
can you tell i don't want it to end i'm
kind of stalling you always okay are
like this you don't want it to end the
peter out the peter out of the episode
if you guys want to write in
to the show we love hearing from you
even though we only read one of these
aloud every episode we allow read them
yeah read them to ourselves we're
allowed all of them we're allowed to
read all of them yeah um our email
addresses life is short wondery.com
thanks for listening i'm gonna try to
just ignore my instinct and wrap it up i
that i think that's growth
i'm impressed yeah i guess i'm not doing
it the longer i talk about it i i
interrupted it
no i by complimenting you yeah no i
can't uh i've lost my footing okay i got
to remember let me help you out yep see
you next week
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted in by woohoo just
alone jocelyn it's co-hosted uh and
produced by you christian christian long
and also produced by megan monaco and
it's also michelle
lands audio engineer on this one and all
most of the other ones is sergio
enriquez executive producer marshall
louis for a company wondering
[Music]
a fortune cookie not only is it supposed
to be a fortune but it's supposed to be
the end of a delicious salty meal where
you have like a little light cookie and
you read a fun ring you put it down and
you carry on with your life right it
shouldn't be a thing where you're like
trying to figure it out for half an hour
you know like it shouldn't be
complicated right you're full
you're like
me probably right
some of your decisions you just made
you're right you don't want to have like
a brain teaser you're right well maybe
this may well oh okay um counterpoint
oh
maybe that's why this is these are so
simple now
it's not simple mine's not simple mine's
so complex
now
yeah strange things may or may not
happen at a party
how could you not think deeply into that
okay well
i can imagine the writer of that is like
um generic on might not like like vague
so it's comforting you don't have to
think about it it doesn't comfort me it
trusts me right right well he wasn't
counting on you thinking about the first
part which is like this might not happen
then don't tell me it at all right if
you're not going to tell me what's going
to happen right away and you're not
going to tell me what it is right then
why are you wasting my time
you